you always want to make sure you clean
the butt cheek mommy
[Music]
it's a long story culture cardi b
reveals how she changes a diaper while
sporting her trademark nails
you know what i'm saying the rapper
offers tips and a tutorial posted to
social media
go like this and i'm saying i go like
that
and i just take it off yup she's using a
teddy bear
nice and long nice and tight
this comes in response to fellow rapper
cash doll who took her dilemma to
twitter referencing nine-month-old son
wave set she asks cardi how the hell do
you change waves diaper with the
wearing nails as long as i was 19.
understanding the assignment and maybe
wanting some extra credit cardi follows
up with a video tutorial and then i just
open the diaper
open up the diaper girl and i just
whoo
and folks this demonstration goes there
you know you got to make sure that you
know if you didn't do too much poop i
just put it all the way down
like that
uh you always want to make sure you
clean the butt cheeks the butt cheeks
the butt cheeks the butt cheeks make
sure it's clean so then you can turn
them to the side you open it up like
this little ball hole you clean the
bubble really good cardi tells cash doll
in the caption trust me you will get the
hang of it however i do feel like boys
are harder to clean
you put the little wee wee up you go
like this you go like that then you go
like this you go like that
then um
um yeah hold on kkk
and cardi's three-year-old daughter
culture she's got some questions why are
you cleaning the butt
it's a long story
[Music]
it's a long story courtship this part is
a little you know difficult but it's
never it's never difficult it's never
hard
just you know you roll it roll it
this comes after cardi and offset
finally shared a look at their baby boy
she took to instagram with these pics
last month looking fresh as he rocks a
baby blue puffer jacket a matching
beanie and white kicks and a love for
motherhood is something cardi b has
opened up to e.t about it means
everything here's what she had to say
back in 2019 shortly after the birth of
her daughter culture it's like a feeling
that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying there's like an
automatic smile she means everything to
you yes and i think i mean i mean
everything to her like i said when i she
sees me she kicks her feet so fast it's
like she loves me
[Music]